Nick Cannon addresses reports he's  dating TLC singer Rozonda chilli Thomas  she's got outstanding an amazing woman  earlier this week rumors started  swirling that the America's Got Talent  host and TLC singer had started dating  et spoke with Nick on Thursday at the  premiere of Gleason in LA where he got  candid about Chile and their possible  new romance we've been friends we got  the opportunity to spend time together  but I wouldn't I would say ask her I  asked her would what the situation is is  if someone I do care dearly for you know  I mean and that's nothing new and that's  not that I would ever be ashamed of I'm  excited when I get to see here and all  my stuff  I'm fresh in this game when it comes to  being single I would be so lucky to be  able to claim to be dating somebody  right